i'm not technically a mother yet because
my baby is still inside me
but in 18 years i definitely will be
so for my son's 18th birthday i'm
leaving him this video message to watch
assuming youtube still exists or you
watch videos on the back of your
eyelids or something
[Applause]
so this is a personal message for my son
on his 18th birthday so you can
scram hi son happy 18th
it's 20 39 assuming time is still linear
and you're heading out in the world
heading off to college if you listen to
your mother or
just heading off i mean you're obviously
a talented soccer player
probably led the league in headers given
how much you headbutt my
bladder in the womb i'm sure you've
developed other talents since then
first off i want to wish you good luck i
know
i've always felt super lucky that you
chose me to be your parent
and i'm sure whatever choices you make
in the future will be just as fortunate
yeah you're leaving the nest but don't
worry about me it's gonna be painful but
hey that's what epidurals are for
assuming in 18 years you can just get
them whenever you want
but you're going off on your own which
means i did my job
even if like an induction you're not 100
leaving willingly you're still getting
out
and i'm proud my advice yeah
the world can be a scary place and i
know like my womb
the house we share is comfortable and
safe
with questionable decor but i assure you
the world out there will be far more
exciting
getting out there will help you grow
from
a fetus to a baby to a boy to a man
to a cyborg which i assume is a thing
now
i mean i've got a lot of advice you know
like hey
don't let me see you sneaking around
smoking weed because
weed's definitely legal now so you don't
really have to sneak
and i don't want to hear about you
kissing other boys
because i want you to just tell me
because it's like totally cool
your sexuality is your business you can
be whoever you want to be i want another
thing i better not catch you stealing
your father's gun
because it's 20 39 nobody owns guns
because we can all shoot lasers out of
our eyes so why would you
[Music]
cyborgs and i know i've prepared you for
the world
because i picked out your clothes made
sure you had a great sense of style
that's fashion
i sang to you so you could learn to
appreciate effort
over natural talent and i
love you i nourished you so you could
grow to be strong this is all for you
baby
i ate the other bag this is your bag
here and you dropped the popcorn
supposed to catch it i hope i've taught
you to be light-hearted and that
you can use humor to get through the
hardest of times like when you wake up
in the middle of the night
to that scene from alien with you trying
to rip out of my stomach and punching me
in the ribs
yeah that scene from alien was
traumatizing but i guess
life does imitate art you gotta laugh
about it
honestly if i'm this proud of what
you've accomplished in nine months
you know like forming a face
sucking your thumb growing internal
organs
i think i'm going to be blown away by
what you have accomplished
in the past 18 years honestly i think
that's the best
part of motherhood watching this little
person
develop his own personalities own
interests his own goals
but at the same time wishing i could
hold you
a little closer for just a little bit
longer
[Music]
as hard as it is for you to go out in
the world
it's hard for me to see you go
[Music]
but i truly am excited for it
it's 20 39 tears don't exist it's 20 39
tears don't exist
go on get out there i love you son
and thank you for giving me the best job
i ever
had motherhood i just wish you paid me a
little more
you